[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes paupières s'alourdissent un peu mais
dans un komètre ou de après le village
on virage dans un petit bar il y a du
feu toi tu dors depuis
l'autoroute fatigué énervé sans doute
plus qu'un kilomètre peut-être puis du
café auprès du
feu je regarde un instant vers
toi tu es presque appuyé sur
moi un virage à droite un peu sec qui te
plaque à moi je voudrais que ce virage
n'en finisse pas je redresse doucement
sans un coup ton visage sur mon
cou passeront les jours et les semaines
et les années tant que je t'urai à mes
côtés dans chacun des gestes de la vie
t'aimeraiis
aussi passeront les jours et les
semaines et les années tant que je
t'auraai à mes côtés dans chacun du
gestes de la viille t'aimerais
aussi
dans une heure on y verra mieux le
brouillard se dissipe un peu les sulac
passent et repasse en laissant des
traces devant mes
yeux des lumières au travers des pH le
village là-bas le B retenant ta tête je
mête sur le bas côté près du
café et dans un bruissement
d'Abe le silence peu à peu
t'éveille je me sens je fatigué mais si
près de toi je voudrais que ce voyage
n'en finisse pas tu souris brusquement
sans un mot ça m glisse dans mon
dos passeront les jours et les semaines
et les années tant que je t'urai à mes
côtés dans chacun des gestes de la
viille t'aimeraiis
aussi passeront les jours et les
semaines et les années tans que je
serurai à mes côtés dans chacun des GES
de la ville t'aimerais
aussi passon les jours les semaines les
années tant que je t'aurai à mes côtés
dans chacun des gestes de la vie
t'aimerais
aussi passeront les jours et les
semaines et les années tant que je
t'aurai à mécter dans chacun des gestes
de la vie t'aimerai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi